hardest part is like making it seem
realistic and romantic is that why you
hate me
sometimes a seemingly perfect match can
in reality be far from compatible
there's nothing better than a movie
romance where you can really feel the
connection between the two actors
but that's not the case with these movie
couples from not
liking one another to having personal
drama to simply having no spark these
actors and actresses shared
very little chemistry with one another
we actually
we have quite a bit of controversial
material
while daniel radcliffe and bonnie wright
did well enough in their respective
roles as harry and jenny sparks clearly
didn't fly when they shared the screen
together
odd because i've known bonnie since she
was about 10.
many fans of the series theorized that
the reason radcliffe and wright's
chemistry was so wooden was because
after many years of their characters
being aromantic
the actual romance felt forced once it
actually came to light
wright even revealed that it felt
strange to kiss radcliffe since he felt
more like a brother to her
it's a bit embarrassing but i think
after a while you just gotta accept it
the vampire love story between kristen
stewart and robert pattinson wasn't as
romantic as fans of the series had hoped
for
i'm gonna kill you if i kiss you or
something and so it's always been kind
of odd
in fact while stars kristen stewart and
robert pattinson dated while filming the
series their on-screen chemistry came
off as creepy rather than romantic
though maybe that's more fitting for the
vampire theme i feel
bad because i don't feel like kissing
you you don't want to kiss me do you
joey king and jacob lordy were actually
in a relationship when the first kissing
booth debuted on netflix in 2018 by the
time cameras rolled for the second
and third film the two had gone through
a bitter breakup
king cited that working with the lordeon
set of the sequels proved to be quite
difficult
but she was at least happy to play ellie
evans again it can be brutal but
you know also happy endings do come
though even from the start it never
seemed like elordi wanted to be on set
while king seemed much more enthusiastic
this led to their chemistry not feeling
as natural as it should have
while the initial romance between
jennifer lawrence and josh hutcherson's
katniss and peeta is
intentionally forced it still doesn't
feel all too believable when they truly
fall in love with each other
just the way lawrence looks at
hutcherson looks more as if she sees him
as a lost
puppy or a younger sibling rather than
an actual boyfriend
like you're my first like real kiss in
the movie though a little abrasive
the original animated beauty and the
beast is arguably one of the most
romantic films ever made
the live-action remake on the other hand
didn't have audiences feeling the love
as much
why is that not a surprise i'm sorry
fans claimed that the romance between
emma watson and dan stevens didn't have
much warmth to it
and in result they didn't feel
compatible to top that off the
recreation of the original's iconic
ballroom dance sequence
just wasn't nearly as memorable due to
the lack of chemistry
plenty of actors who would have looked
at me far stranger than emma ever did
natalie portman is one of the most
talented actresses currently working in
hollywood
meanwhile chris hemsworth carries a lot
of charisma as a leading man and has
carried it through
countless blockbusters that's why the
pair's lack of chemistry in the first
two thor films was so disappointing
[Music]
sorry i just needed to make sure you
were real it's been a very strange day
while their respective characters are
certainly interesting on their own
their romance comes across as forced and
even a tad
boring it's no wonder why taika ytt
decided to break the couple up
in thor ragnarok there's nothing wrong
with women of course i love
women sometimes a little too much chris
evans and hayley atwell's chemistry as
steve and peggy helped make their
romance one of the best
love stories in all of the mcu this is
one of the many reasons why evan's
chemistry with emily van camp feels
so unnatural vancamp doesn't get much
screen time in either the winter soldier
or civil war
especially not enough to make her
romance with evans feel real
in result the kiss between the two just
felt like it came from out of nowhere
and was one of the most questionable
moments in all the mcu
we're just glad marvel decided to leave
that plot line behind
and i wanted to be the superheroes i
didn't want to kiss him
the relationship between the joker and
harley quinn is one of the most
prolific romances in the comics so it
came as a pretty big disappointment when
stars margot robbie and jared leto
didn't seem to share much chemistry with
one another
oh we have got company
one of the reasons may have been that
robbie wasn't too thrilled with letto's
method acting and became fed up with him
when he kept sending her gross gifts
such as a dead rat
another reason why their chemistry
didn't work may have been because letto
and robbie never rehearsed together off
camera
it was like a bit weird to begin with i
i
never met a famous person before the
romance between aquaman and queen mira
is supposed to be one of the most
compelling love stories in the dc
universe
i just saved your life i see just first
unfortunately stars jason mamoa and
amber heard lack any sort of chemistry
their romance doesn't feel either
interesting or engaging
instead feeling dull and boring even
their epic
underwater kiss doesn't feel all too
romantic i'm not going to compare it to
anything
because it really feels like its own
movie johnny depp
and angelina jolie were at the heights
of their careers when they did the
tourist but their chemistry just felt
artificial and robotic
what didn't help was that jolie and depp
didn't get along at all
on the set of the film jolie hated
depp's partying lifestyle while depp
found jolie to be stuck up
pushing aside the iconic upside-down
kiss in the first film toby maguire and
kirsten dunst's dynamic just doesn't
feel
as romantic as peter and mary jane the
pair had
actually been in a brief relationship
but had broken up not too long before
filming for the second film commenced
making their scenes together feel even
more awkward
and that starts to create conflict in
his relationship with mary jane
compared to andrew garfield and emma
stone's dynamic
and tom holland and zendaya's chemistry
maguire and
dunst just didn't have that spider-man
magic
in their romance unlike some of the
other actors and actresses on this list
chris pratt and bryce dallas howard do
work good together
just not romantically in fact their
romantic scenes come across as forced
and ultimately
forgettable by the time the second movie
rolled around
audiences completely forgot that they
were even a thing by the end of the
previous film
despite their lack of romantic chemistry
pratt and howard did get along great
while filming and eventually became
close friends even when rumors were
swirling that the two were feuding both
actors
quickly denied any hard feelings towards
one another we've been having fun this
whole time it's
great leonardo dicaprio and carrie
mulligan are both
stellar performers and while they may
have looked good together their romance
wasn't
nearly as memorable as the story
required it to be
feeling much more like an afterthought
at that point in her career mulligan
hadn't become the major star that she
has become today
in fact she revealed that she was
freaked out by dicaprio and his star
power
and even found working with him to be
intimidating despite him trying to help
her out
is she good enough is she going to be
the she was in his own imagination
seth rogen and catherine heigl have both
gone on record to say that they found
each other
extremely hard to work with while the
raunchy romantic comedy is a crowd
pleaser it was definitely hard to buy
the accidental romance between rogan and
heigl's characters
yara shahidi and charles melton may
shine in their individual roles on
television but their romantic chemistry
in the sun is also a star
just isn't up to par their chemistry
simply felt awkward and even the changes
the movie made from its source material
didn't make the two performers chemistry
feel
any more believable it was possibly most
like one of the most unromantic things
to like shoot if you were in that
environment
melton revealed that he was quite
nervous to work with the grown-ish star
especially after reading that oprah
winfrey had revealed herself to be a big
fan of shahidi
there are countless reasons why an
actor's chemistry with their co-stars
wouldn't work
which makes it all the more important to
find the right people for the roles
are there two actors or actresses that
you felt didn't have any chemistry